hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt sanierer sitzt heute dabei
und ihr seid jetzt hier beim vierten
teil meiner grimm reihe
ich werde es heute nämlich eine leckere
salsa sauce machen mit tomaten und dazu
ein paar auberginen und ein bisschen
zucchini mit anbraten
natürlich könnt ihr eure saucen auch im
supermarkt kaufen für wenig geld aber
ich motiviere euch wirklich dazu möchte
ich dazu anregen dass ihr diese saucen
selber macht weil erstens mal wisst ihr
dann was drinsteckt und zwar ins mal ist
es euer eigenes rezept oder jetzt im
prinzip mein rezept was ihr aber
natürlich selber individuell umgestalten
könnte und dass ich auch eine super
geschenk idee denn ich werde dieses soße
dann später in so ein kleines fläschchen
abfüllen und dann könnte das ganze auch
richtig gut verschenken
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal meine
zutaten und zwar habe ich hier zwei
auberginen und drei zucchinis die
brauchte jetzt nicht für die soße
sondern dazu wird die soße einfach dazu
anrichten
hier habe ich fünf tomaten das in etwa
500 gramm ich brauche etwa drei
esslöffel olivenöl etwas pfeffer und
salz salz habe ich einen halben
teelöffel zucker habe ich eine kleine
briefe hier habe ich noch eine zitrone
davon verwende ich etwas zitronensaft
eine knoblauchzehe sie habe ich noch
eine charlotte zwei scharfe chilis das
ist jetzt einmal nach a la peña und das
ist eine peri peri und ich habe es hier
noch ein bisschen frischen oregano
könnte auch getrockneten nehmen oder
auch weglassen oder natürlich auch ganz
eigene kräuter benutzen zu öffnen ist
jetzt eure tomaten vorbereiten ich
möchte jetzt schälen und zeige mich
jetzt einfach mal ein tipp wie ich das
mache ich schneide meine tomate irgendwo
kreuzförmig ein und legt sie ihnen eine
große schale
und dann nehme ich heißes wasser kochen
des wasser und sprüht das ganze auch das
lasse ich jetzt einfach kurz an der
seite stehen
bis ich den rest vorbereitet habe und
bis dahin hat sich dann die schale von
der tomate gelöst und ich kann so schön
abziehen
in der zwischenzeit stehe ich schon mal
meine charlotte könnt ihr übrigens auch
rote zwiebel nehmen die charlotte die
schmeckt etwas milder als eine normale
zwiebel ihr könnt natürlich auch eine
ganz normale nehmen
aber ich nehme immer mal ganz gern
schalotten ich muss aber auch dazu sagen
ich vertrag zwiebel nicht so gut und ich
schalte ich einfach milder im geschmack
die gebe ich jetzt einfach hier drauf
immer darauf achten dass dieser schutz
drauf ist zum saubermachen und
knoblauchzehe die halbjährig war er noch
das habe ich jetzt hier schon
vorbereiten kann jetzt meine tomaten
nehmen und ihr könnt es jetzt hier auch
schon sehen im wasser dass hier die naht
die ich vorhin aufgeschnitten hatte dass
die tomate bereits aufgegangen ist er
holt jetzt mal raus können jetzt hier
sehen und das kann ich jetzt ganz
einfach abziehen und die tomate so von
der schale entfernen
viele schilder die tomate in rohem
zustand da habt ihr aber das problem
dass ihr dann zuviel schale mit weg
wählt und so könnte eben die schale ganz
dünn abziehen habe nicht so viel müll
zum wegschmeißen und ihr habt noch ganz
viel tomate übrig ach so ja die tomate
die stele ich von ihre waffen klo
händewaschen
die tomate wird geschält weil die schale
in unseren salz steuern würde also die
ist die klett am gaumen zum beispiel
wenn man sie kaut und die wollen jetzt
einfach nicht drin haben wir wollen eine
richtig schöne tomatensoße ohne diese
harte schale jetzt habe ich hier meine
fahne die wird jetzt grad heiß da gebe
ich jetzt etwa drei esslöffel olivenöl
mit rein und da kommen jetzt die
schalottenwürfel mit dazu mit dem
knoblauch würfeln und es lasse ich da
jetzt schön am dünnsten nehmen die
temperatur auch etwas runter auf etwa
mittlere stufe damit sie nicht
verbrennen
in der zwischenzeit wirklich schon mal
meine tomaten und die mache ich jetzt
nicht in dem schneidegerät weil die
einfach so weit sind wir sind ja schon
fast ein bisschen gedauert weil ich sie
im heißen wasser hatte und diese tomaten
würde ich niemals in einem schneidegerät
schneiden weil man die dann einfach da
hab ich einfach nur vermischt und das
wollen wir nicht
sie hilft die chilischoten werde ich
jetzt noch klein schneiden und es wartet
mit handschuhen weil dir wirklich extrem
scharf sind wenn sie euch zu scharf sind
nehmt ihr die kerne heraus denn die
kerne sind es was an der chilischote
eben dass schafe so richtig ausmacht ich
nehme sie jetzt mal mit raus weil ich
nicht weiß ob kinder mit essen
die sind zwar ein bisschen schaaf
gewohnt aber nicht übertreiben
die hab ich jetzt hier auch kurz kleiden
paprika immer mit der hautseite nach
unten auflegen
den rest hab ich da jetzt einfach kurz
unter hier guckt mal das kommt alles
schön raus muss man fast nichts mehr
sauber machen
die schafft es richtig richtig und ich
merke im handel ist der hals brennt
jetzt nicht gegessen habe jetzt gebe ich
hier als tomaten und es lassen wir jetzt
einfach hier ein bisschen vor sich hin
köcheln
so etwa zehn minuten bis das bisschen
eingedickt ist und dann werden wir das
ganze noch würzen und fertig stellen und
in dieser zeit werde ich schon mal die
aubergine um die zucchini kleinschneiden
findet das ganze auch mit etwas zucchini
und auberginen agieren wollt dann könnt
ihr jetzt einfach nehmen und klein
schneiden und zwar entfernt war hinten
das ende und schneidet sie jetzt einfach
in kleine scheiben so wird es gern
gehabt
die auberginen die gebe ich jetzt in
kleine schüssel und zwar müssen wir
jetzt ein bisschen gesalzen werden
und die lassen wir jetzt ganz kurz
stehen das könnte auch theoretisch ganz
am anfang machen bevor ihr das
zubereitet denn so werden sie jetzt ihre
feuchtigkeit verlieren und eben wässern
und das hilft uns einfach später dabei
dass die aubergine später nicht so viel
fett in sich aufsaugt im juni die
aubergine ist so wie sie ist grillen
oder braten direkt auch ein feuer mit
etwas öl dann nimmt sie zu viel fett in
sich auf und das wollen wir ebenso
verhindern
ihr könnt jetzt theoretisch auch noch
ein löffel tomatenmark dazugeben
damit eure soße natürlich auch richtig
schön rot thematik könnte aber auch
einfach so lassen ich finde so sieht sie
nicht schön natürlich aus und jetzt gebe
ich hier noch einen halben teelöffel
salz die prise zucker dazu schmeckt das
ganze mit einem spritzer zitronensaft
mit dazu noch mein oregano
das habe ich hier ganz frisch gepflückt
da nehme ich einfach eine schere und
schnippelt es hier direkt mit in die
pfanne
so sieht jetzt meine fertige soße aus
ihr seht die fahrradfahrt fertig in
dieser flasche auch eine schöne
geschenkidee und ich habe jetzt etwa 15
minuten dafür gebraucht fünf minuten
arbeitszeit 10 minuten köcheln lassen
ich werde es die soße hier stehen lassen
und weit noch kurzes gemüse anbraten
hier könnt ihr sehen dass die auberginen
richtig wasser verloren haben hat sich
hier die flüssigkeit die werde ich jetzt
mit kaltem wasser abspülen damit das
salz eben weg kommt weil sie ausdrücken
und sie dann hier gemeinsam mit den
teenies anbraten
die zucchini es gebe ich einfach schon
mal in die pfannen einfach auf so etwa
mittlerer stufe einfach jährlich zahlt
im wasser etwas abspielen wasser
ausdrücken und dann das
gibt es hier einfach umstritten weil es
ziemlich spritzen kann dass es kurz
andünsten
und dann kann ich das gericht von
verlieren
ich würde das ganze jetzt noch ein
bisschen mit ein bisschen pfeffer und
salz
das gemüse ist schön weich gegart und
dann gebe ich das direkt in den
servierteller ich kann mir das jetzt
noch ein bisschen basilikum und fertig
ist das gericht dieses gericht und einer
anderen grillgerichte gibt's natürlich
auch selbst orten welt.de ich verlinke
euch jetzt gleich noch alle videos dazu
und ich wünsche euch natürlich einen
guten appetit und dieses antipasti
übrigens schmeckt auch ganz gut als
vorspeise als jetzt nicht nur zur
grillzeit sondern auch allgemein als
vorspeise und das schmeckt aromatisch
sehr lecker die tomaten sind sehr
fruchtig und ganz witzig also bislang